he influenced the many stories that we
have at link
they were basically designed based on
what pelter did
[Music]
hello chest hello hey steve
how are you i'm fine thank you
mom thank you you know
uh today i have i'm really pleased to
have a chance to talk with pyotr
for a variety of reasons first of all
because when i was learning
polish a pyotr his material is what
helped me
you know get to a level now i've
forgotten so much polish now but
at least if i was able to speak at all
i'd largely credit
pyotr from getting for getting me to a
level where i could start listening to
audio books which i found from publio
uh krapka pl which has a great selection
of audio books and ebooks and stuff
but you you have to get to a level where
you can start using this material
and that's where piotr comes in so that
was the first thing we're going to talk
a bit about this
about his approach and of course he
influenced
the many stories that we have at link
they were basically designed
based on what pilter did so let me ask
you please explain
how did you get into the teaching of
polish online
at realpolis.pl what motivated you to do
that and how did you come up with this
wonderful
storytelling style
okay so thank you for having me here
steve you know it's an honor for me to
be here and speak with you
you know i was at my 40s and when i
started learning
english because all my life i
i just thought i'm not able to learn any
language
because of school and that story with
grammar
and so boring materials that i was
thinking it's not possible to learn
english
and one day i i decided to learn
you know i wanted to understand only
english so i was looking for materials
on the internet and yeah i
i found this aj hope podcast
and day by day i i just
listened to it and i found these stories
and those stories with questions and
answers was
so so interesting for me the voice of
i don't remember there was a friend of
aj hogue
named joe weiss he has a great voice for
me
i i really like to listen to his voice
his american accent and all this stuff
so it was really interesting for me and
after i don't know maybe it was six
months
of yeah really into it i was really into
it
i was using it for six hours a day
or more because i
i work uh i work on a computer as
a graphic designer and i was able to
listen
a lot so yeah
i i found that it helps me a lot
learning english you know and and that
point i thought
maybe i i should start learning
and teaching polish the same way can i
just
one comment here before we get into the
start of real polish
aj hogue is also a great inspiration for
me and i think for many people
effortless english is his program he's
influenced a lot of people
all over the world more than the british
council or any of these other
institutions
aj hogue has helped more people learn
english and he developed and i think
it came through this uh tprs movement
and
there's a lot of people who develop this
approach to storytelling
uh point of view stories where you
change the tense or you change the
purpose
or with these circling questions and so
we've all benefited and we've all
learned and i think in this world we all
learn from each other the second point i
wanted to make was
that you found a person whose voice you
found agreeable
that's so important i have to tell you i
found your voice
very agreeable and if you if you are
going to listen and we have to listen so
often
you said six hours a day i mean i was
listening to polish polish stories your
stories
and there's your voice is very pleasant
there's no tension
and i think that's also very important
so i just wanted to mention those two
things
and now let's get back to how real
polish began yeah and
i i have to add that aj hogue
give gives me this spirit of
entrepreneurial
which i started to
think why maybe i i should start
something for me you know my
own experience in in a business
because you know i i was growing up in a
communist country where it's
not it's not a common way to
work as a entrepreneurial
you know so it was kind of
not easy for me to start but his
podcast and teaching you know
it was a great influence for me so yeah
i start
and right now i'm really happy i i did
it
so i i learned
english and almost the same way i
started
learning spanish i used
your website to start learning spanish
and i after some time i
i found an oscar from barcelona
excellent
same idea yeah same idea
yeah so yeah i i
i made more more stories
in polish i have 100 stories
then i thought maybe i i could
make something for
level level up you know
something called intermediate learners
and
i make i make a podcast
it's not not so easy
but i think we can find an
easy content all over the
internet it's it's not it's not a
problem for
if you're starting learning any language
it's
it's easy but right at some point you
you there is a lack of of good materials
so i thought maybe it's a niche for me
so that's why
yeah okay um
again a couple of comments on that there
are there there's lots of beginner
material in every language
every time someone does produces a book
on how to learn polish or
indonesian they come out with a beginner
book with the same boring content uh you
know the doctor's office the train
station
uh whatever ordering in a restaurant uh
but your material and i'd like to think
our many stories and aj hogue and oscar
is also beginner material in the sense
that there's so much repetition
whereas in the typical book there's no
repetition you have you go from the
train station to the post office
to you know the doctor's office and and
there's
things don't repeat so whereas in your
material and in the many stories the
same vocabulary repeats in these
point of view stories it repeats within
the story so i think it's also very good
beginner material
but there is an abundance of begin
beginner material for most languages
and there is an abundance of very
difficult material
so i can find podcasts in arabic right
now in al jazeera
what's lacking is that intermediate
material
and it's difficult because word
frequency declines so quickly
so you can repeat the basic you know a
thousand words in your
beginning stories but pretty soon you're
introducing words that
are not so frequent and so then it's the
important thing is to make these things
interesting so that people keep on
consuming them consuming them consuming
them and eventually they
they you know acquire the words that
they need so that's in a way a challenge
how how have you been able to so your
basic stories are very good
and their everyday life and it's simple
stuff and i think that's what's so
clever it's somebody who
makes uh coffee in the morning or he
drives to work or
it's all the things that happen in our
daily lives
but how about that intermediate material
how do you find the subjects for these
podcasts
oh yeah you know it's like
i'm looking something for
which is interesting for me so when i
preparing a podcast
i listen in a spanish or in a
in english about a topic that i can
present in polish so
i just want to
to use this time of preparing me
that works for me as well as a language
learner
not only a teacher i i don't consider
myself as a teacher
i just provide a a new content for
for polish learners that's it
and just i want to
learn something for from my work as well
so this preparing process is a
learning time for me it's just simple
as that so you know and
go ahead sorry i i wanted to mention
that
all there are there are
approach of teachers who tweets
who treats language learners as a child
and and it for me it's a little bit
um i don't know i don't like
it because i think i agree when um
there are people who don't speak polish
but they're
they are really intelligent they they
know
a lot of they more a lot
more than me about i don't know
different stuff so they're not not
stupid they're not
a child so i don't want to treat them
like a child
so i agree i think
and you know yeah sorry go ahead yeah
yeah i think
that something is interesting for me
could be interesting for others as well
so
that's my approach i think this is so
very important that uh
i feel the same way like right now i
have a collaborator in iran
and she creates material for for link
and i look forward to whatever i get she
sent one just yesterday
on this uh which is a
iranian soup and how to make it and the
ingredients and uh
yeah why it's important and and then she
does so she typically does
five minutes about the soup and then she
has five minutes of these circling
questions
so i'm learning about the soup i'm
learning about the cuisine of iran
she did one on the history of iran so so
i'm not
consciously trying to i agree with you
so many of the sort of youtube videos
will be like uh you know they'll have a
whole three minutes on how to say
like they'll conjugate the verb vuluar
like you may watch that video whatever's
there you're gonna forget it
it has no impact what you have to do is
is get the language
in in genuine context into you so your
brain
starts to get used to it and and uh okay
your your mini stories or the
your early stories are after a while not
so interesting
but yeah you can then bring them as
intermediate content things that are
where they're learning so i learned
about the history of poland or i learned
about polish food or
i learned something interesting about
poland
i'm not aware that i'm actually learning
the language at the same time
yes that's the point that the goal is
maybe not learning a language the goal
is
enjoy the process and learning something
about history learning something about
culture
and you know the there is
no day i i i could say i learned
i learned spanish or i learned
english that's enough i'm done right
so and so i just started using it
as a
yeah i i just use a language as a
method of learning something about life
about culture about history you know
that's it so it's it's a tool language
is a
type of it's a tool one type of content
that i'm
i want to explore more and which we've
done a little bit of
we did it in ukrainian and in in persian
is to just get people to talk about
themselves so i'm a student
or i work in i.t or i do this or i do
that
i went last year with the family went
for a trip to uh you know
austria so people just talk about their
lives so we have a collection that link
called the iranians
and you you meet say
10 or 15 iranians who talk about their
lives i have no idea what people in iran
do how they live what their concerns are
what their hopes are yeah and so
you're getting to meet these people
you're getting to know these people and
by listening to their stories
uh and typically when people just talk
they use less difficult language
uh as com as compared to literature okay
i can go
get a book of polish literature it'll be
very difficult for me it's hard but if i
get a bunch of polish people saying oh
yeah we went
we did this we did that i'm at school
whatever i think that kind of content
too is an area that we can explore
yeah it's like everyday language
it's it's different than language in a
in a books or textbooks
it's yeah it's something
yeah it's we should
sorry yeah yes it is a great content uh
listening about other culture what
people
how people live in iran or
yeah it's really interesting canada
poland
we should form a group you're the
spontaneous natural
content creator society
yeah it's growing i can see it's growing
because
when i started it was 10 years ago
it was only you i don't know maybe
oscar luca oscar and
moses mccormick and that's that's it i
remember
professor argelius but he disappeared
i don't know why it was really
interesting
yeah a little more academic but his you
know
shadowing method was yes really
interesting for me
i use it a lot with questions and
answers i
tried to mimic
those stories so it was yeah it was
useful for me
okay listen i thought we might finish up
uh
trying to speak with me trying to speak
a little bit of polish oh great
and uh and uh okay
the problem per problem a
movie proposal
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
it's a struggle but i i just wanted to
say you know people sometimes say oh how
do you maintain your languages
and i often say well like polish like i
i would have real trouble
like in spanish or french or whatever
it's not a problem but say in polish
it's a problem but it's not really a
problem because everything that i have
invested in polish
it's still there and so i can't
immediately speak polish
but i understand polish and if i were to
go to poland
i think within a week i would and even
if i mix in the odd word of ukrainian or
czech it doesn't really matter people
understand you and i understand yeah
i understand every word you said so so
that's not a problem
[Laughter]
every word everything was was perfect
so there are a little bit mistakes but
yeah
but understandable so there is
there is no issue when we get more
opportunity to use the language we do
improve
so i think a lot of people learn the
language sort of at home
away from where the language is spoken
so obviously they're not going to speak
so well
and especially if they don't you know if
they leave it for a while but
when you again get the opportunity to
use the language
you will improve and and we i think you
will agree
we are always improving if we have a
positive attitude yeah
yeah of course i have the same issue
with my spanish so
i speak quite well in spanish but
i have this level that i can reach
more without going to spain or
any country spanish speaking so
so i think i just on the same level for
i don't know maybe two years but
it's but you enjoy it it doesn't matter
yeah i enjoy
listening speaking with my friends
through the internet so always
my goal is not a decide that
it's it's finished my spanish is done
so my goal is to use a language
right so yeah yeah yeah okay well listen
it's been really enjoyable we should do
this more often thank you
and maybe we should form a group with aj
i met aj for the first time
in japan and he's a great guy
and oscar of course i've met and so
there's a group of guys that are
creating
more content more content there's uh
uh in french i've seen it in spanish and
italian
so we are revolutionizing yeah
yeah the world of course okay you
did it you did it thank you
thank you for having me thank you and i
can't wait to
agree about it more polish and i have to
visit poland
i have never been to poland definitely
definitely
when this all this pandemia were
finished you you are invited here
i'm looking forward okay thank you thank
[Music]
you
[Music]
you